[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
April 27th I'm most Nolly for the Wall
Street Journal filling in for J.R Whalen
until recently many Executives had been
hesitant to push too hard for in-office
attendance fearing workers could quit in
a hot hiring Market but one Law Firm
whose clients include some of wall
Street's biggest banks and other
companies has told its staffers working
fewer than the required in-office days
could lead to lower bonuses I'm joined
by chipcutter who's been looking into
this for us chip which companies are
trying a different approach and what are
they doing to get staffers back into the
office yeah so it's the white shoe Law
Firm Davis Polk and it's told staffers
that those who don't adhere to its
policy to be in the office three days a
week could see their bonuses affected
and this is notable because we've seen a
number of companies try recently to get
more people back in the office and
they've done everything from holding
special in-office events some have
brought in live music even many managers
have sent sort of increasingly
threatening memos to people but until
now not many companies have actually
said that they're going to Taipei to
in-office attendance and so I think
that's why this is drawing some
attention for example some companies
like JPMorgan Chase have sent memos to
staff in recent weeks telling them that
those on hybrid schedules would be
expected to follow them we've also seen
a number of prominent employers
including Disney Step Up in office
requirements to four days a week you
know during the pandemic we saw a number
of employers say that people needed to
be in two or three days a week
increasingly we're seeing big companies
say really needed before some cases some
companies are saying five days a week
and so I think all this comes at an
interesting moment because for so much
of the pandemic employers were really
really concerned that it was hard to
hire and that it was hard to keep people
right now though the power dynamics
between employees and bosses are
beginning to shift and as big companies
do layoffs a number of CEOs and other
Executives now feel more emboldened to
push for changes that they've wanted for
months now
so post-pandemic workers are adjusting
to these new hybrid work schedules in
your reporting you found that offices
remain kind of empty especially on
Mondays and Fridays what are companies
doing to tackle this right it's somewhat
surprising but even more than three
years into the pandemic at a number of
corporate sites offices aren't always
that busy and if you look at sort of
occupancy figures and 10 major U.S
cities it's hovered around 50 now for
weeks and you talk to a number of
Executives and they say that they walk
their floors and it's still rare to see
a lot of people at some companies on
Mondays and Fridays in particular while
an office might be busy Tuesdays
Wednesdays and Thursdays and so that's
still raising questions about what
companies do with their real estate do
they consolidate floors do they think
differently about how they have people
in offices but a number of Executives
have said we're sick of this we want
people back in person more often and so
you see them resorting to sort of new
tactics including what Davis Polk has
done which is to say that your bonuses
part of your bonus could be your
adherence to the firm's attendance
policy and this is for associates and I
think it's just been interesting to talk
to the chairman of Davis Polk and to get
his view on how all this has happened he
said that he's taken tough questions
about this and employ all hand sessions
and he said he's not sort of backing
down from this he thinks it's going to
work first off and that he thinks people
will follow it and he said most people
in The Firm were already complying with
the attendance policies but this was
just to try to create a little bit more
of an equitable environment and to say
that performance is going to be judged
into Lots different metrics including
adherence to the in-office attendance
policy Executives early on had been
loathed to push hard on office returns
fearing workers would quit what's
changed well I think what's changed is
that the labor market has changed a year
ago you weren't seeing lots of companies
layoff workers or announce hiring
phrases right now though it feels like
you can't go a single week without
seeing another prominent employer saying
that they're going to trim some of their
staff or pull back a bit on on hiring
and it's just been notable used to hear
Executives on earnings calls just say
how difficult it was to hire how they
were really struggling with retention
and now they're talking all about
efficiency and productivity and sort of
trims that they might be making to save
money and so workers have experienced
this they realized they don't have as
much power as they did earlier in the
pandemic so I think some employees may
not feel like they can push back as much
on bosses when they do Step Up in office
requirements but that's not to say all
companies have given up on this a lot of
companies have realized that flexibility
is here to stay a number of CEOs have
said that they do feel like just three
days a week two at home is fine but I
think a number of bosses just trying to
realize like what works best for the
cultures of these companies are they
noticing for example that early
employees aren't adjusting to the
culture aren't sort of succeeding in
ways that maybe more experienced
employees are and so this is why some
are changing policies but it's I think a
different labor market right now and
that's what's allowing some companies to
make these changes chip is this a state
of things to come well it really remains
to be seen because an number of
companies have put in really sort of
strict attendance policies and they say
that people still have not followed them
and it really comes down to sort of how
managers enforce this and it's memo to
employees JPMorgan Chase for example
said that it expected managers to ensure
that their direct reports follow the
policy and so like any workplace so much
of someone's experience depends on sort
of who their boss is and how they
interpret a company's policies and I
think even on return to office issues
we've seen really mixed messages some
teams just insist on having everybody
back and other bosses say they really
don't care you know chip amongst some of
these policy changes what options do
employees have if any employees don't
have tons of options here companies are
within their rights to ask people to
work whatever way they like unless it's
a union environment that might have a
different bargaining process for most
white-collar employers companies set the
terms and bosses set the terms here and
so companies can say we need you back
five days a week and employees will be
expected to follow that what employees
can do is look for work elsewhere or try
to find more remote friendly jobs that
has become more difficult the number of
jobs sort of available fully remotely
has dropped in recent months and so it's
not always super easy to find that new
position that might provide that kind of
flexibility but companies are you know
able to impose new terms and then
employees have to decide if they want to
go along with it all right that was Wall
Street Journal reporter chip cutter
thanks for being with us and that's your
money briefing I'm most anali for the
Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you